how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the mcu and in
today's video we have a
very very interesting topic the hulk's
return
to the marvel cinematic universe we knew
that it was inevitable
we knew that mark ruffalo wanted to
return we know that he's been confirmed
to be appearing in the she-hulk series
coming to disney plus
but how exactly is he going to be
returning and which
version of the hulk are we going to be
seeing when he finally does make that
return to the mcu
now there's been talks ever since
avengers in game that we could
ultimately see the hulk become a villain
something that has happened a few times
in the comics
and in this video i'll be breaking down
a recent report
rumor and talk about how we could be
getting the most powerful version
of the hulk in the mcu and how we could
even see
the avengers go up against the hulk
sometime
in the marvel cinematic universe so i'll
break down everything that you need to
know about this new hulk report in this
video but first if you're new
be sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest
mcu news and so you can enter this
week's giveaway for a chance to win a
mysterio funko pop
just subscribe like the video and leave
a comment down below to enter
now surprisingly a lot of people don't
actually have
that big of a problem with the hulk
becoming a potential villain in the mcu
and this mainly comes from his story arc
and avengers end game a lot of fans
weren't too excited or happy with how he
really
ended what we now know as the infinity
saga with
smart hulk we didn't see the hulk really
at all in avengers infinity war and
the smart hulk that we got and endgame
didn't hulk out
at all and that's what everybody really
loves about the hulk
hulk smashing and for those of you who
truly miss that in avengers in-game we
have some pretty cool news to talk about
today
as it is being reported that we could be
getting the
immortal hulk in the mcu at some point
now the immortal hulk is very very
different than
all the other versions of the hulk it's
a fairly recent hulk and in fact
some of the recent issues that have come
out in marvel comics have been pretty
horrifying a mortal hulk can actually
only come out at night time
and this is kind of odd because in some
instances
bruce banner will die during the day and
the hulk won't save him
until night time so in some cases bruce
banner has died and has been dead for
several
hours before nighttime comes and the
immortal hulk
comes out the immortal hulk is quite
possibly the strongest hulk there is
he's also very articulate and smart and
he's also very vengeful and aggressive
the immortal hulk tracks down people who
have done wrong
and instead of just finding them and
smashing them like the normal hulk would
he finds them and actually has a
conversation with them
he tells them what they did and why he's
about to pound their faces in
literally and he even listens to what
they have to say before he smashes
and the immortal hulk is a lot stronger
than the incredible hulk once he hit
thor so hard that it knocked a tooth out
gave him a concussion and caused him to
need serious medical attention after the
fight
he once hit she-hulk so hard that she
flew two miles away
and he completely destroyed the
hulkbuster armor these are all things
that the regular
incredible hulk could not do and to top
it all off he has faster regenerative
powers once the immortal hulk had a
giant hole blown
right through the middle of his chest
this was pretty shocking considering the
fact that it seemed impossible up to
this point to even wound the hulk let
alone blow a giant hole into him
but it was even more shocking when the
hole immediately closed up and healed
itself
so this is a very different hulk than
what we're used to dealing with he's
smarter
and faster and according to a new report
from the roger wardell account the
immortal hulk
could be coming in a recent tweet he
said that the hulk's next iteration is
going to be based on both
dot green and immortal hulk story lines
now many of you know
roger wardell was the person who leaked
a bunch of stuff about avengers in-game
all of which ended up becoming true
he was seemingly locked out of his first
account for spreading all of the leaks
and now he has a new one which is this
one
now doc green hulk from the comics comes
after
merged hulk which we basically saw in
avengers in-game as
professor hulk what happens is bruce
banner ends up getting shot in the head
multiple times and in order to save him
tony stark
exposes him to the extremist virus
something that we've actually already
seen in iron man 3 but the extremist
virus causes the hulk to become
even smarter and what ends up happening
is we actually get kind of the opposite
effect of what we saw in avengers
in-game smart hulk
you see smart hulk was bruce banner in
control of the hulk's body but
doc greenhulk is the hulk in charge of
his own
body with intellect smarter and higher
than bruce banner
now doc green hulk and the mortal hulk
are supposedly
both stronger than the incredible hulk
and they're both
smarter so again what we essentially
have here is going to be an
opposite of the smart hulk it's going to
be the hulk controlling his own body but
he's extremely
smart now this is a pretty good move by
marvel if this truly is happening
because again a lot of people weren't
really that happy with professor hulk
and the immortal hulk and doc greenhulk
are very different but kind of give
us exactly what we want a smart hulk who
actually smashes
but there is a catch to doc green hulk
dot green is neither bruce banner nor
the hulk and he actually asks people not
to call him either of those names he's
an entire person differently together
and he comes up with a plan to hunt down
and cure all gamma-based mutations that
include
she-hulk red hulk and any other hulk
variations that are not bruce banner but
he ends up having dreams that he becomes
maestro hulk so he decides to not give
himself the extremists anymore so he can
avoid becoming maestro hulk
however ultimately the maestro hulk
would get sent back in time and would
fight the hulk but that story may be a
little bit different from the mcu
maestro hulk could be debated as the
strongest hulk there ever was
he has bruce banner's intellect but he
has increased gamma radiation
which makes him incredibly strong and
maestro hulk in the future would rule
the entire world and maestro hulk if he
came to the mcu would end up being
the villain and this could be a form of
the immortal hulk and
maestro hulk the immortal hulk gets so
strong that in the comics the avengers
go after him
and they end up fighting and this seems
to be a version of the hulk that we're
going to be getting in the mcu according
to this leak a dock green immortal hulk
so essentially we have a immortal hulk
that could
potentially turn into maestro hulk which
is bad news which
means the avengers are going to have to
step in and not only are they going to
have to fight the hulk they're going to
have to fight the strongest version of
the hulk that they've ever seen
in the mcu now it seems very apparent
now that marvel's master plan for the
next 10
years is to lead up to secret wars
battle world
and maestro hulk has a connection to
battle world in the battleworld event
god emperor doom would ultimately end up
ruling and maestro hulk would attempt to
kill him so this could be an incredible
story arc for the hulk and the mcu
completely different than what we've
seen in the past we can see the hulk
turn
from somebody who's kind of a merged
hulk professor hulk
transform into essentially a brilliant
brutal hulk and then eventually into an
evil version of the hulk that would
ultimately end up turning good
again this would be an incredible story
arc that i think a lot of fans would
like to see and it would be really
awesome if marvel studios is truly
planning on introducing
a variation of the storyline one that
they make up and based off of doc green
the immortal hulk and maestro hulk in
the marvel cinematic universe and i
think this would definitely make up for
some of the fan's disappointment of
professor hulk and avengers in-game yes
he did snap and bring
all the people who were snapped back to
life but again fans were pretty
disappointed that we never saw him hulk
out so of course this is not confirmed
it's just a rumor for now but if marvel
studios is truly planning on this
what do you think about it would you
like to see this iteration of hulk
in the mcu where he becomes even more
powerful even more smarter
ultimately becomes the villain but then
at the end tries and helps everybody by
defeating
god and prayer doom let me know what you
think about this in the comments down
below
don't forget to give this video a like
and subscribe so you can stay up to date
on all the latest
mcu news for live updates you can follow
me on twitter and instagram and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof
you